like if I can ask them a question would
you guys want your wives I don't know if
you guys are married but would you guys
want your wives to work I didn't know
[__] no no why no well listen because
why I'd rather them raise the kids like
well why I'm gonna provide I'm gonna be
the one bringing the bread home I don't
want her to because I don't want to have
to work out a necessity that's a lot of
pressure to put on men that aren't able
to earn salaries where they can feel
pressure makes diamonds yeah and that's
not hey look that's Darwinism that's the
best thing for the species do you guys
ever think that maybe there might be
like she was speaking about that five
percent five percent chance that you
might get run over a call you might get
[__] or something you know well I
didn't I wanna I wanna finish the most
typical guy who who is gonna have to
wear with also if that situation if that
eventuality did occur she would be
looked after even in the uh in the point
of History to live your life out of fear
like what if the worst case scenario
happens and I think a lot of times as
women we kind of go into situations out
of fear instead of thinking about like
what good could happen
[Music]